there are four new cases of the disease
including two health care workers who
tested positive of the virus and a
medical center in Brighton on the south
coast of England is now closed overall
there are eight confirmed cases in the
UK for more on this let's speak to dr.
Richard doors he is a specialist in
travel medicine joins us live via Skype
first of all what does this declaration
from the Health Department mean well
we're now entering uncharted territory
because it's actually a very very long
time since quarantine laws have been
invoked in this country but basically
the new escalation of the level of
public health threat that has been
declared gives the public health
authorities the right to legally detain
people in order to prevent the spread of
disease when you say it's been a while
how unusual is this particularly within
the region are there other countries in
Europe implementing these measures I'm
not quite sure what's going on in other
countries but the last time we had
quarantine legislation enforced in in in
in the UK in the mainland UK you've got
to go back as far as the plague
outbreaks of the 1600s to find actual
quarantine being enforced there was a
village that famously quarantined itself
in 1665 there's legislation that dates
to the 1700s as a result but that was
never used there's legislation that
rates to shipping and the last instance
I've confined that was in the 1890s when
ships returning from overseas were
quarantined right so that really puts
into some historical context for it for
us doesn't in terms of what prompted
this declaration now how important is it
that these new cases came into contact
with someone that was previously
confirmed case so in other words has
been a lot of debate about there these
so-called super spreaders people that
really do shed quite a bit of the
and that can really accelerate
transmission so at the moment the
quarantine rules mainly prominently
apply to people who have been brought in
from China and particularly emergency
rescue flights from program Hubei
Province and so initially there was a
kind of an individual contract that was
offered to each of people who was
returned so the issue is that it's not
much fun being stuck in quarantine I'm
sure that there are lots of things that
we would add to anxiety such as concerns
about possibly becoming infected by
contact with a fellow
quarantine II so it's not surprising
that people will feel the need or the
anxiety and what to kind of discontinue
this arrangement that's really what's
prompted this escalation it's not that
the threat has changed so much as the
willingness of people to remain and 14
days is a long time to remain in under
quarantine conditions appreciate your
time thank you very much dr. Richard
Darwin